بعد كثير من تراكمات الخطاب العدائي بين
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ورغم
الثقه المفقوده بين الجانبين وكثره
الملفات الشائكه لم يعدم البلدان النفاذ
من اضيق الابواب الى تفهمات عبر الحوار
تجعل الصعب ممكنا وما كان للحوار ان يتم
لولا دبلوماسيه قطريه منحها الطرفان
ثقتهما وكان من نتائجها ما شهدته الدوحه
من وصول خمسه سجناء امريكيين قادمين من
طهران الى قطر للذهاب من بعد الى الولايات
المتحده
ويشكل الافراج عن السجناء الامريكيين
مقابل خمسه سجناء ايرانيين من السجون
الامريكيه تتويا لحوارات طويله توسطت فيها
قطر الطائره التي جاءت بالامريكيين الخمسه
الى الدوحه ستقل ثلاثه من السجناء
الايرانيين المحررين الى بلادهم بعد ان
تخلف منهما اثنان مؤثرين التوجه الى بلد
اخر قطر التي حصدت ثمره جهودها قال رئيس
وزرائها ووزير خارجيتها الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني ان بلاده مستمره في كل ما
من شانه تعزيز امن المنطقه والعالم ولا
يقف الاتفاق بين الجانبين عند تبادل
السجناء بل يضمك جزء منه فك الحظر المفروض
على اموال ايرانيه تبلغ نحو سته مليارات
دولار
وقد تم بالفعل وفقا لافادات المسؤولين
القطريين والايرانيين ايداع هذه الاموال
في بنوك قطريه تحت ما تسميه واشنطن
بالقناه الانسانيه التي تمكن الايرانيين
من السحب منها لاغراض انسانيه فقط
وحذرت الولايات المتحده من انه في حال
خروج الصرف عن هذه الاغراض وهي مما يتصل
بحاجه ايران الى المواد الغذائيه
والدوائيه والزراعيه فان واشنطن ستعود الى
فرض التجميل على الحسابات
وايما كانت العقبات التي قد تنشا في تعريف
ما هو انساني فان الاتفاق يمثل اختراقا
كبيرا للدبلوماسيه في كسر جمود العلاقه
الايرانيه الامريكيه مع ضخامه رصيدها من
سوء الظن ومن التربص فما اكثر ما وقف
البلدان على حافه المواجهه في مياه الخليج
والمواجهه العسكريه هي ما تحرض عليه
اسرائيل امريكا للقضاء على برنامج ايران
النووي وكانت اسرائيل قد رفضت الصفقه التي
تمت بين الولايات المتحده وايران زعمه
انها تشكل دعما لما تسميه اسرائيل الارهاب
الايراني وتعزيزا لقدرات طهران وهو امر
سيكون بمثابه تراجع خطير عن استراتيجيه
الاحتواء الامريكي بحسب اسرائيل الغضب
الاسرائيلي الذي فشل في تعطيل الصفقه كشف
عن تقاطع للمصالح الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
ربما لمره بهذا الوضوح من جانب اخر بدت
الصفقه التي سعت فيها قطر بيانا في
امكانيه الذهاب ابعد الى مقاربه القضيه
الاكثر تعقيدا وهي ملف ايران النووي الذي
بقي منذ خروج واشنطن منه على عهد الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب سببا لتعزيم العلاقه
مع واشنطن والغرب تاره ومع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذراع الفني للقوه
العظمى لحراست نادي الدول النوويه ما يدخل
عليها داخل الا عنوه واقتدارا صنع الهند
وباكستان وكوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
واذا كانت الدبلوماسيه القطريه ستجد دفعا
وتحفيزا بما حققت من نجاح في صفقه تحرير
الانفس والاموال فان ايران ايضا ربما وجدت
السبيل الدبلوماسيه اكثر جدوى واعجل فائده
انه براح يوفر طاقتها في السياسه وفي
الاقتصاد ويجعل ما يبدو مستحيلا امرا
ممكنا